oh can I look up the cast before no no what do
you mean no no no no but when you don't let me
do that stop stop now don't even read
okay tell me when you're ready [Music]
first of an intro because it's our final one it's
Final Destination five we love this franchise we
heard this one's gonna be great Final Countdown
that's my prediction for what song's gonna be in
this you got one Greg I'm gonna wait to see what
it looks like the disaster depth is gonna be and
then I will call the first thing that comes to
mind okay I take back what I said I'm gonna do
that too I want to really quick thank all you
guys of course for being here this has been
one of the most fun franchises to cover been
loving it and Craig Perry who's been in our
comment boxes showing us love and I appreciate
also the encouragement to let us uh be openly
critical about some stuff we don't feel like
we need to mince our words whatsoever yeah
he's kind of agreed with us I know but overall I
love the franchise and I already can't wait for
part six even though we haven't seen part five
yet leave a like subscribe all that good stuff
ooh I'm loving the dance moves on this right
now also be a patron why don't you you should
already we have full length Reaction watch
logs where you sink up with your own copy
and that's how you can be a super sexy reject
I remembered every word of it Greg yeah you
didn't read it at all didn't even look like it
no Greg and John cover several shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included let's do it
thank you okay guessing who's in it just
thinking of names right now Adam Brian
Christopher Daniel did they eliminate
the 3D I totally hear you Roxy over
[Music]
oh hell yeah oh no no they're giving you the
castle okay remembering it Nicholas I don't
know who you are but I will Emma Bell Emma Bell
Emma Bell that sounds familiar Miles Fisher who
that name sounds actually familiar that's gonna
bother me I know that name could be miles tellers
long lost Courtney B Vance he's huge Courtney
B Vance let's go Courtney B Vance Arlene Esco
escarpeta good have you seen the pronunciation
people versus OJ David oh yeah David kochner
oh I know him he's a comedian yeah I know him he's
funny he's a funny guy and Tony are there clues in
this intro we're missing so we saw skulls we saw
shattered glass we saw what looked like a hot dog
but I don't think was this is a dynamite is that
a hot dog I'm gonna guess the song We Didn't Start
the Fire oh that's a really good guess no no I'm
gonna go with the Doors Light My Fire oh that's
a really good guess too all I can think of is
Bruce I'm on fire or Bruce Fire but I don't
think this movie's gonna use a Bruce Springsteen
song just not correct Perry or dude let's go Craig
get it Craig this is when prepper has the most
fun editing okay barbecue picnic yeah a breakfast
picnic waffle are they on set isn't this amazing
thanks man just uh remember that when you see my
sales report for last month I saw it last night
it's okay I'm trying to make a decision Miles
Fisher is that him yeah I recognize him from
what he looks like Christian Bale and he's
played Christian Bale a lot on YouTube videos
your tickets canceled I was going to tell you
after this weekend uh tell me what I don't
know that I don't think it's such a good idea
what the trip what why not Heartbreaker it's
not working out soon I hate to hear it at
least you didn't ghost the ghost didn't even
exist then but that 12 30 curfew tonight you
should plan on breaking that why for the naked
team building naked team building baby get it
that's where you see some boobies that's what
we do with all our interns here at real Rejects
I love that name that was cute we got
a gig on uh Sunday yeah I'll be there
I already think this movie is better it just
paced better I'm knowing the characters do
you actually get paid for this internship or does
daddy just increase your allowance if you want to
get rid of that baby fat you should try the gym
yes that baby fat yeah I know she's disgusting
they're called I love this movie things that are
keeping me interested you know how many things two
things two predominant things the glasses yeah
we're doing like a really really good listener
by a lot of ladies wait don't say anything
tell me it's the camera from last Tuesday
when people say shh to me
I want a punch in the face
I'm joking I'm sorry
there he is yeah Whammy I want to be on the road
in 90 seconds uh well I just saw his car so I'll
go track him down way to show some initiative
Stan it's gonna be a good day you know what
this intro is doing a really good job at doing
is is settling you into this genre not the horror
part of it like it's it's just being yeah that's
the world that it is right now before the horror
happens I think that's really good the other ones
are just like we're already in a horror movie what
would you call the genre I don't know just some
like comedy comedy yeah what are they gonna offer
you that permanent gig at the restaurant they
already did they want to send me to the flagship
restaurant in Paris for who knows how long could
be six months could be a year in Paris is this a
prequel that's enough from Paris no the first
one was pretty cool I'm with you that's a good
prediction there's got to be some big twist
in this or through line connective tissue
here we go hey Sam bus crash is that
what we're gonna get what are those for
just something I do to relax me and for luck luck
get out of the bathroom sir Ball's the New Black
okay so his initial seat is up there but now
his seat's back here is that what threw it off
you feel like it's usually a choice from the main
character that throws no I know but remember the
plane from the first one we know where your c ends
up is where you die and that's we got logs again
are we gonna get like some amalgamation
of all the other ones Maybe [Music]
hey Greg gloomy day
I think the cinematography is so much better
also when is this because it just
seems like it's way more modern
oh snap
clever really give the audience
a sense of how far that fall
[Music]
Dust in the Wind I didn't predict we
did not call that we did not call it
maybe Sail On nothing was the was the chance we
had to predict something sail away from me honey
or float on oh interesting so this is going to be
more of a weather effect we're
in the elements the elements man
all right okay budget all right this was good
Molly come on [Music] I know that you
don't want to be with me but I will
save you great shot yeah oh where why is she
going that way that was not a smart bad intern
there's a crush
a three day that was was it
3D I can't tell no pulp 3D
holy moly are there people on the bus still I
think they're just not one
guy oh oh that a great shot
damn that's a hell of a shot
right there that was cool
are your boobs okay is okay
wow there's like a real Disaster Movie
[Music] the bridge is so thin we can do this
you can do what why are you guys going that
way I'm so they gotta cross it oh good I
can't go the other way if you pencil down
can you survive that fall no I don't think
so I think it's like cement when you hit
good for you Molly
oh wow do you feel it
but maybe those would help
her float Olivia [Music]
Molly grab her oh like a slide [Music]
maybe she's arrived yeah we let her float
yeah that's helping her float
no no don't get hit by the car
oh [Music] awesome okay but what that taught
us is that if you go down you can survive oh
this is an interesting concept
because maybe she's the only
one in his vision who doesn't die yeah
and therefore she's safe for the movie
foreign
oh no how unfortunate Hot Tar
s oh way to go Tom Cruise
damn good jump the effects
are amazing so maybe their
lives aren't at risk maybe they
all three made it no matter what
yeah what a shot this is a really good effects
who knew climb it like a ladder
oh the eye I think this was in 3D
like a paint can
oh [__] okay so he's the
main guy first yeah we knew
[Music]
I predicted this would come on again we all got
to get off the bridge is gonna collapse what we're
all gonna die what the hell is going on we're
all gonna die if we don't get off this bridge now
what if what if things which eventually happens
that'd be crazy would you listen yes or no no I
wouldn't somebody who's that you knew said we're
all gonna die if you don't get off this bridge you
wouldn't get off no I would think that they're
just having an anxiety attack about something
Peter please just follow up Peter Peter pumpkin
eater what the hell is going on out here
do you still think that is gonna be okay no
I don't know I've just gotta wait for
some like other twist yeah [Music]
come on
why would you stop running because they're
on Solid Ground now or something you know
they're not where the bridge is so they just want
to watch why wouldn't you get your
cell phone and record this [Music]
and they all survived not all of them everyone on
the bus survived every single person got off yeah
I saw it collapse I knew it would happen I had
a vision psychic phenomena you don't know how
I'm out of nowhere did Sam have issues with
authority did he ever is hearkening back
more to part one this inner cutting in the
interrogation room and people thinking it's
his fault you see him talk to anyone
that morning on a cell phone Payphone
just his girlfriend but that was in person thanks
good guy Miss Molly tell me about the breakup
I think we're doing the song choice
that's personal I'm chucking up the high winds and
structural damage from remote construction I wins
yeah I'm sending everyone home high winds have
high winds ever caused that much of a structural
damage on a freeway before I mean maybe if there
is a tsunami or something like yeah a tornado
employees of pre-sage paper on their way to
a business retreat the other 17 employees
were killed in the collapse bad on the bus
or there was another bus what the our main
characters survived yeah I knew that but you said
everyone I didn't I forgot about the other guys
presage baby pre-saged paper maybe this
is in the same universe as the office
Thunder Mifflin yeah you heard the news it's
natural causes yeah more like Supernatural
we cannot have more than one black person in
these movies it's the surviving teens hey we
got a black cop and now we got two black people we
should all just put it behind us and be grateful
we're still alive man the eyebrows on him I was
seeing that eyebrows and dimples killer that's
handsome mom maybe you work next to them maybe
you work for them but we all worked with them
huh this one's feeling like a very refined version
of the other ones but it's still going through the
same beats so I'm waiting to see like you know
what I mean yeah not feeling like a major drama
Tony Todd doesn't like to be cheated tell
them early you all just be careful now
okay thanks for the advice
no there's got to be something more to him I I
feel like he is still kind of Supernatural yeah
he's some entity of sorting he can't just be some
guy well what's the matter with it he said it was
flat no flavor do they want something else yeah
the check I would hate to work in a restaurant
oh he's looking out for him yeah
but also don't eat something that
the customer has eaten you've
never done that before have you
no you have I don't know I mean
sometimes you're just a plate of fries
in your eyes Boombox outside that's not
how improv works you don't just go no
all I can say is that my life is pretty plain
did she die in the first Vision I
know he died but did she make it
she did make it yeah or at
least he didn't see or die
man they really took note of the last one of being
like super [__] like fast and they
really taken their time with this one
listen they're letting that gloomy Vibe like wash
over this whole movie getting you to safety you
are the only thing I care about Molly she cheated
on him Paris we talked about that I'm not going
to root my life for that job but it's the only
thing you've ever dreamed of huh life is too short
Sam you you have to go after what you love you
can't make somebody else's choices for the molly
I do like her now though Rachel stayed behind
I have her dreams to be in love and I rooted
for it we all did without realizing that
Rachel gave up her dreams I don't know
I'm just not ready I don't feel ready oh my
God she's about to die I think you got this
really yeah I mean you love it out there oh she's
gonna fall and break her neck or something yeah
something disgusting is gonna happen gymnastic
injuries are gnarly I do think this one so far
is doing the best at letting The Grieving element
actually wash over all the characters there we go
could be a red herring they've got to
make it cooler or we're going to pass out
they're working on it you're going
to regret asking for that lady
why does he seem like a villain
come on Candace got this
chalk your hands actually being supportive
to each other I thought they were just like
a sexual fling and then they're actually like
dating dating oh no it broke it's bad luck
what's up Sizzle Sizzle Scorch Scorch now I pass
the torch the ballots are
in and one girl had to win
oh good frame
[Music]
so this actress must actually be
a gymnast or a dancer because she
looked legit oh no oh no that would be so
painful oh I hate it I hate it I hate it
I've stepped on a nail before
and it is not a pleasant feeling
it's a little screw right
oh and I want to mess you on the sound design
no no no no no no no no no it's good be good
oh no nicely done
done
geez I'm super glad she didn't step
on that have you ever stepped on a
nail it's really painful no I don't think so
Candice stay loose that's funny screw loose
oh no she's gonna hurt herself on the thing
the way they shoot that makes it look like yeah
it's really cleverly done looking good Candace
somebody she's gonna scream that's what's
gonna happen she's gonna scream and then
it's gonna throw her off other girl's gonna step
on the nail he's gonna thrown off oh that's sick
[Music]
whoa love the disorienting shot there
what is that somehow these screws are going to
come together dude no what
no no no no no no no no no
okay
wow wow
oh that was gnarly oh my God holy [__] that
was [__] insane call 9-1-1 Candice Hershey's
a pretzel yo that was that was great I knew it was
gonna be this other girl threw her off in the that
was great the way they ex that's so much tension
and the build to that and then the way it all
like actually collapsed that was really well done
let's see if they do what you wanted which is have
the boyfriend actually mourn she was doing great
she was almost finished with the routine and then
why why did it happen why does life happen
it's okay Peter it's okay that
you're a pumpkin eater [Music]
oh Tony Todd is back okay so yeah maybe he's just
some like Angel of Death thing yeah I feel like
you've got something with Paris yeah that's
a bummer about Candace I guess we all should
have seen that coming gotta dig at what you see
the crazy [__] those gymnasts do I'm surprised
it doesn't happen more often she's so insensitive
Candace was mean to her though remember she told
her to lose the baby weight oh yeah yeah so
it's warranted what she said yep same level
it's funny because he works he's in the office
too that is funny Greg oh isn't that funny
Debbie Downer so naughty [Music]
what is he playing his pockets I don't know I have
no idea what he's doing he's creepy he's gonna get
himself killed is he just randomly stealing [__]
yeah I guess I'll attacks oh he was the second one
to die right I think so you shouldn't have buddy
I actually don't know the order of I just know the
last three were eyebrows who wants one where'd
you get these I stole it I got something better
uh oh our manga though seems to have adjusted
the fact that we had a pretty crazy premonition
you know what I'm surprised the main guy
is not like stuck on the fact that he had
a big combination yet how's he gonna die in a spa
romantic dinner you know somewhere maybe outside
the city hold up I gotta go he's so creepy I know
if he was really good looking it wouldn't be as
creepy you know what I found out Roxy's never had
a massage before that's true that's insane yeah
kind of freaked out by it ironic the family
operation this professional experience and uh
exactly what you need I hope she rips his
dick off yeah you have a lovely little Cantor
yum yum dim sum see she's gonna put
another dude big dude why is this guy
such a dick yeah he's the worst you're going
the wrong way there little lady well foreign
okay I'm sorry do you come with subtitles gosh
he's doing like Chiropractic stuff whoa ow
you're a little aggressive there don't you think
okay you're a little aggressive [Music]
it's not how massages usually go but I don't
know but I don't want you to be scared this
is why I don't want a massage I want to drink with
my co-workers massages are great they're necessary
[Music]
oh the shattered glass like the opening it
says scariest roller coaster on it I did see
that that's a reference to the roller
coasters yeah of love she dies doing
something that she's done almost every day
for the last 15 years of her life she said
she didn't want to do it and I should have
stopped her no you're being supportive honey
oh sad boy there wasn't anything you could
have done how do you know okay helpful I'm
sorry I'm sorry oh becoming a villain not hot
doesn't he seem like it seems like a young Tom
Cruise Peter just freaked out about something
I don't know what does that mean anything you
for a movie that's so serious sometimes
the comedy seems kind of very out of
place I could try it a hundred times and
never recreate exactly what happened here
[Music] I think it's just die oh yeah awesome
and acupuncture is that what that is I think so
I've never done acupuncture I thought they were
thinner than that you know I do like how smart the
cop is I was not just writing it off like he feels
like there's actually Something Happening
Here you understood that you speak English
two billion people can't be wrong wow two billion
people can't be Wong oh the joke is that I get it
get you wrong I thought I said two banging people
oh wait wait wait it's great so the table's gonna
break and those are gonna all go super far
inside him food acupuncture is great for you
it's not very nice you know I constantly
have shoulder and back pain Craig
ah don't move it's gonna go in his eye
or something I just can't you're like
reminds me of the dentist
scene you look so comfortable
30 minutes
table breaks and then he's uh it's just Greg
just stop it just stop the movie yeah it was
so uncomfortable I know what's gonna happen
what's gonna happen table's gonna break and
then he's gonna fall and those are all
gonna go into him and he's gonna die bro
that's a lot of candles for one massager yeah
probably something with fire too my dude uh
oh
hey fire get up it's usually not as bad as
you imagined it to be actually sometimes
it's way worse why isn't he getting up I think
he's like slightly parallel oh there it is do
it do it knew it knew it knew it knew it
knew it Greg knew it knew it I knew it I
knew it I knew it he's gonna light on fire
bro I mean you should still be alive yeah
ew that is gross no I don't want to
see his face don't show me his face
dude get out of the room out of the room get out
of the room I thought that the acupuncture meters
were so much thinner than that yeah but for
cinematic purposes they need to be disturbing
no oh his phone I guess he's gonna go
back for his phone shut the front door
what a dumbass yeah it's like a ride there oh my
God it wasn't so bad I asked you to stop I'm sorry
Tony Todd see at this point I would be like going
right up to Tony Todd and be like what the hell
is going on why are you following us what are you
doing ask more questions yeah lucky few survive a
disaster and then one five one death comes for the
wall um would Doom to die you're supposed to die
on that bridge you're not supposed to be here he
actually sounds sympathetic to death have somebody
else in your place and then you take their spot in
the realm of the living and they take your place
in death we kill someone we get their life I don't
make the rules interesting it's about to be the
purge yeah he laid it out pretty clear for the
first time yeah but those happened in the rules
every time yeah I know but he actually like was
pretty direct about it and now it's coming after
the rest of us no not all of us she lives Molly
made it she didn't die when I had that Vision
I got you a cross before the bridge collapsed
because you decided that you deserved to live
more than the rest of us apparently you deserve to
live more in Candace so unreasonable see that it's
been quite a while since your first consultation
a lot is going on in my life I don't want to miss
anything Lasik no I think she is the next one on
the list and then the black guys after her gonna
die during Lasik this is like the dentist all over
again damn this movie is doing everything I wanted
to do I wanted to go get acupuncture and I want
to Lasik I'm gently going to position your head
that's cool that's one word for
it Greg I can't move my head
comes to drop you will feel I actually can't
watch half this movie it's just an eye drop
huh Grammy has to get shots in her eyes oh my God
every month that's horrible yeah she's a trooper
okay all right this might be a little boy
Craig fast forward Greg not fast forward
oh that is gnarly oh
oh this movie knows how to toy a little toy
stuffed animal with us they're not even doing
anything gross yet it just feels that way
uh looks good what's that mean oh what a
shot that is a disturbing ass shot oh no no
the eye on the ground the eye of the tiger
did you know what my assistant's giving me an
incomplete file I'll be right back [__] this
oh [__] elements bro it's always
elements always the elements you're
right about it man I laughed at you
on the first movie but you're right
you know the toyed around with electrocution
a lot but we haven't actually seen it maybe
until now I don't think that's it no no no no no
no no no nope nope nope use your hands use your
hands you have your hands use your hands oh the
cheer ducks wait what is what is it laser coolant
Greg do I have to duct tape your eyes open
and keep Greg I don't even like her hands
I hate her hands no no no just move your help
nope nope she can't move her head dude [Music]
oh no
all right oh Olivia castle where is she she might
be in danger there she is he
not the water the water [Music]
whoa
oh
is that what an eyeball would look like driven
over maybe so I want me to find out I literally
warned you about what I couldn't do this would
someone really just smash through the window that
easily I think windows windows are so tough aren't
they I don't know I want you to tell me what you
think is going on two deaths okay all right that's
a coincidence three pattern pattern yeah baby
catch up let them in you gotta talk to his other
sophisticated black guy who knows a lot of stuff
we think we weren't supposed to survive on that
bridge and now something is trying to write that
that's all you got but what is the entity that
provides premonitions to these people maybe Tony
Todd's really trying to save their lives so he
gives them the premonitions we all got off the bus
but the ground gave away in Candace fell then the
bus tipped over and Isaac he never got off the bus
he went with it you getting at the order first was
Candace and Isaac I'm Olivia who dies after Olivia
you knew yeah I remember that but we haven't had
somebody get skipped I feel like it's about time
it's a great setting for a cool death
contraption what if they get in a fist
fight and he doesn't mean to but he kills Royce
dies no he kills Roy and then he gets to live
oh is he deciding right now to kill him I think
he's trying to make a choice to kill him on
accident cut my hours corporate has operated
less than 50 until this whole thing blows over
my Boogie ain't operating at 50 my dumbass kid
ain't operating let him die [Music] let him die
[Music]
oh that extra little Banger told you they're gonna
get in a fight yeah you predict that right he did
try to save him though but he ended up pushing him
to his death Olivia and Isaac are dead Who's Isaac
Isaac Palmer tech support wasn't he dead already
Dennis must be next right I'm not [__] around
here Dennis anyone could be next it could
be you was he next on I think so because
the three of them we weren't supposed to survive
that bridge collapse and so now it's kill or be
killed literally what's the girlfriend's name
Olivia Molly Molly lived what if we're just
watching Molly's Vision the whole time that'd be
interesting but she's not seeing all or I guess
she could be seeing it and not being there that
would be fascinating correct even the other movies
five is a lot of movies for a franchise to be able
to make and make them fresh with the same premise
you kill him no no I it was just time you know
he got in the way and no you did didn't you
you you saw coming and then you took his life it
sounds like Tom Cruise it really does yeah yes I
killed him you traded spots he should have your
death I think there's an orders of these deaths
he looks so happy who wants to be the first to
tell me what the hell just happened who is this
yeah who's what we needed to save some time
is Dennis no [__] oh that's a really gross
one yeah damn that seemed like a little bit of
a throwaway but I'm okay with it they're like
there's gonna be a solid 90. something saved me
on that bridge maybe it doesn't want me to die
oh my God he thinks he's Invincible I like this
so if it happens tomorrow or 50 years from now
whatever as long as we're together I'll be okay
why don't you come by after my shift and I'll make
you a nice late dinner oh what if they get on the
flight to Paris there's got to be some cool twists
right and he just wanted passengers who dies
that would be really sick that might be what
it is Greg Greg I hope so Greg Greg we've got like
15 minutes to find out if that's what happens ha
unless death is now suddenly coming for
him no it's not his turn bro yeah but
these are all like the classic warning
signs for somebody else maybe you know
how they see signs for somebody another
person but there's no one else here yeah
but it doesn't always isn't always somebody
else there remember when the other guy died
in the shower and he got that floating
thing that said the guy's name [Music]
there's been a lot of meat things I
feel like somebody's gonna go through
I should stop filming reactions
hungry yeah I know I want meat
nope nope don't do it man
yeah I'm not smart nope nope
I don't know I thought he already unplugged it
it was a second plug if the offer still stands
I'd like to take it it's yours that's cool if he
makes it there you're so right he's gonna get on
the plane that is crazy if we don't know if
that's even what happened I'm positive dude
The Internship
ooh his lips are gonna be red why aren't they
Tony Todd oh no oh no he's gonna cause a problem
he's the next to die something with the meat do
you mind if I come in oh course yeah come in no I
do mind so you're gonna just kill him maybe Peter
did kill somebody always really yeah I can
believe that that's why it's this guy's turn
Peter it's good that you're here you shouldn't be
alone right now still alive I'm next to go right
it's me and then you isn't it maybe he kills try
to kill Molly he looks just like Christian Bale
from Batman Begins take someone else's life if
I could actually kill some stranger can't do a
stranger he's gonna try to kill Molly or maybe he
already did it that's what I said yeah I went on a
walk every couple of minutes an opportunity would
just present itself like like clockwork that girls
hahaha
he didn't do it yet I couldn't kill
somebody that didn't deserve to die
yeah so I love The Descent of this guy and
he thinks Candace didn't deserve to die who
deserves to die he thinks Peter or Sam for
saving Molly he's pissed at Sam none of us
deserve to die then why is it you deserve
to live bye oh Molly you said it yourself
oh [__]
stop he's gonna get fired this is just like
Titanic shots fired requesting back a 10-26
Washington go she didn't seem panicked
enough I mean she's not the my favorite
performer I spit when I said enough I
just want you know I know you're not a
killer I don't want to kill anybody
Sam I don't want to die yet either
oh [Music] don't worry Molly ooh is he turning
the deep fryers on yeah turn everything on dad
I actually really like the choice of
what they're doing with this guy it
smells like psychological turn they've
done with the character well we've had
almost everyone with McKinley and
[__] but this guy like we liked
yeah it's one of the main characters yeah
don't bring a butter knife to a gunfight
oh no don't kill the cop what's going
on there well at least it took a life
now you don't need to kill Molly right you
have blocks life you're safe now she just
witnessed the murder of the federal
agent thank you this is smart whoa
oh
the deep fryers the surprise
oh the guy is the gun heats
up is it gonna fire yeah
and somehow he's got to get on the plane to Paris
or we're just gonna arrive at the ending seeing a
final destination one it's one of the two [Music]
done Tell Candace I love her Peter wowie and
now he killed somebody who was saved so now he
lives yeah but then how's he gonna live on the
plane to Paris death always comes back around
not if you take somebody's life then you traded
places it's only if you get skipped pay attention
to the rules Greg that's right it's gone you
killed him so does that mean I get Block's life
yes I do but he wasn't expected to have
a long life Brock no you don't get their
life expectancy you just get to live you
trip places is this it must be because I
take the window seat are you kidding me
you're gonna make me sit in the middle
seat this is the first movie to not mention
the other incidents that has to be a prequel
[Laughter]
that was really good Greg
now I'm impressed with myself
[Music]
that's why we didn't know the year of that
one [Music] it's in the Wind I knew it would
play again he sees it there's like one thing I
don't like about this and I'll tell you after
Vision no
no oh so anyway they can survive us
she dies because she switched seats
with him I mean I don't think so even if
they fell out like there's no way yeah
no damn foreign
okay maybe death is just coming to collect
still can't believe he's gone though
yeah he's kidding the planes just gonna fall
in here company did an autopsy for insurance
purposes turns out Roy had a large blood
vessel in his brain so big he's about to
burst they said he'd be dead any day now so
maybe you do take their life expectancy yeah
the plane yeah
Die Young oh five four three two one oh
is there a meaning to these credits I I don't
think so I think they're just showing us like
the greatest hits oh yeah that one's sucked
oh yeah that one was gross too that was awful
oh yeah oh yeah I actually kind of like
them reminding us as oh yeah that was
awful oh there were no boobies in this movie
well there was like booby illusion [Music]
you all just be careful now huh interesting okay
okay okay okay okay the one thing yeah tell me
don't like about that is wow you're so negative
I know okay this was a great finale not like we
just start off on a negative okay I wanted to
start off with a slight tinginess one thing you
don't like about that is is I feel like on the
plane that incident where Alex was freaking I
think it was his name Alex when he was freaking
out maybe I think he thought that it was Alex
last time too right okay whatever I know what
you're talking about yeah yeah um what's the
actor's name again when Devon saw was freaking
out that was such a thing on the plane that I'm
like everyone heard that on the plane no you know
when you're in the bat he was far away and that's
why they had that woman ask like what was that
about I think they were trying to justify it and
mask it I think that is that's something they
would have overheard and they probably would
have been quite I think there would have been
a discussion because he was saying the plane's
gonna explode and all this he was saying all these
things and when you say some [__] like that on
a plane everyone's going to be talking about that
I don't feel like they were just like oh I guess
that was nothing like the everyone around because
he could still see them fighting he was in there
he was in the proximity of seeing them he could
see them fighting here's a net you want to pick
no no no no no no no man this is a name if he's in
the eye line to see them fighting then he should
have heard the conversation and and to me that
is that's not a nift I feel like he should have
just they should have really established her in a
completely other cabin or something like that to
not have heard it I don't feel like they didn't
establish that they're not in a different cabin
he looked over and he sees them before he
sees but we don't like we're seeing a camera
shot of them fighting we're not seeing
his eyeballs see or his ears hear them
you're not wrong but you're picking at it maybe
maybe okay what did you think of the movie
it was really good um what do you
think of the characters this time
um I like the I like the characters I mean
okay look let's put this out of the way it is
and every second of this movie is a massive
Improvement upon the last one yeah yeah like I
thought from the very beginning I was like okay
this is already a significantly better movie
and I think the characters overall are better I
love what they did with the friend Miles Fisher
I love the way they handled him because he
while we've seen shades of that happen with
other characters before we really gotta watch
this guy transform over the course of the movie
he starts off as the like this the Plucky most
charismatic confident one of them all and you're
watching him fully descend in a way that felt
natural throughout the movie that by the point
he gets to like killer mode I really bought it
and it didn't seemed like overly telegraphed
um but like sometimes some a choice like that in
a movie you can see coming very early on and to me
it wasn't like very predictable but by the time it
happens it's very believable that it's happening I
think if you're gonna I'm surprised that you say
that because well I accept it I think if you're
gonna pick Nets Jesus the fact that he is more
willing to kill Molly because he says why do you
deserve to live when Molly ain't down [__] yeah
and he's more willing to kill her than a stranger
I I thought that was a bigger leap okay
yes which I was okay with but I'll meet
you there on the Molly thing I think a lot
of that is a an envy that he was projecting
uh onto like just a pure jealousy he was
projecting onto his friend that his girl gets
to live and he chose to save her and the whole
thing with the premonition like I I think there's
some justification it still is a leap yeah I know
I hear you and I agree there is some justification
I thought that he did they did a good job him
and Molly being the the core couple in this
kind of carrying this and all the other characters
I was interested in too so it's your understanding
that the you're taking that person's life whatever
their lifespan would have been right that's why he
ends up dying on the plane that's why um yeah
the other guy dies in the bar at the end and
I think that's why they made it very clear
I think that's why they they chose to show
I I remember anyone's name the black guy um
what is anybody's name in this there's Molly
and Olivia Sam and Peter Pumpkin Eater I don't
know what the black guy's name was either we can't
look racist Rock I don't know what David cokers
gotta remember the black guy's name look it up
but I'm not gonna edit this out we don't remember
the black guy's name I don't remember David's name
Roy no Roy was the guy the white guy who
died who's Roy the guy who the black guy
I said I didn't save killed oh oh yeah
that was right what was the name of the
creepy guy at the at this massage
parlor that's good we don't know
no we've balanced the scales yeah
um uh but I think that's why they established that
at the very end to to clearly State that's why
um our main guy still died I don't remember main
guys in I think that's why they they established
Sam I don't know if that's right it looks like a
Sam but that's why yeah because yeah the second
he killed his friend I was like but the guy was
expected to die yeah so like the life expectancy
would be short what do you think of Tony Todd
of it all for not just this movie the the entire
series franchise except for that tennis ball
racketed to you what was your um what was your
takeaway you can't just take my question man I
just want to say you up I've been talking more
cool um I just think he has such a presence that
he brings so much validity to these movies that
seems so weird but like he's an icon and so to
even have him I'm not saying that the reason
four wasn't good was because he wasn't in it but
for him to be in every other movie and four to be
the one that sucks I don't think that that's a
coincidence no like I I do think that I I wish
that there was a little more explanation for him
at some point like why he knows what he knows or
did this happen to him maybe we see that in the
sixth one or maybe something more to how this is
what he is what he has to do with death how this
has all come to be but in general I just like
his presence yeah I love his presence a lot here
well he said some interesting things here because
he was saying that he's seen this happen
before and this is in the timeline this is
before the first movie right that's what I'm
saying like how does he know did it happen to
him so yeah it's it's like damn it's been going
around this guy's life for sounds like forever
forever I don't I feel like they should ever
really explain it though I think keeping it
in mystery and I'm sure there's like a
bunch of YouTube videos that break it
down and try to try to explain maybe what
is what his background is but what how
would you feel if the sixth movie was
Tony Todd big prequel prequel and him
um I would know this is 2011 so that doesn't
make sense I wouldn't like it because if he's
the main character we know he won't die yeah you
know and I think a lot hinges on that feeling of
because out of all the movies only in part two
is when when the people survive right yeah that's
kind of crazy out of five movies right with the
barbecue yeah well clear survived the first one
that is true but then she didn't survive
anymore that is true that is a good point yeah
I wonder how they are going to go about this
sixth one because this is such a complete Loop
and they did a really good job of relating some
of the stories and having them be relevant keeping
it fresh bringing us back to the Paris plane you
know what what's left what stone is left unturned
I heard someone pitch that they should be on a
cruise dude a lot of people die on cruises because
and correct me if I'm wrong and I'm sure I am but
something about can't be charged international
waters rules are iffy nobody's looking for
them to get thrown overboard I'm telling you
I it sounds right I think that Hassan Minaj did a
uh episode on cruises um for Patriot Act whatever
that sounds plausible yeah the cruise thing that
would be really interesting and we're stuck there
but then how's yeah that would be interesting
though because you would think they would just
stop the cruise right or do we stay on the cruise
I have no idea man Titanic what'd you think of the
characters in this one I definitely dug them but I
don't think it's a coincidence that we're having a
hard time kind of distinguishing them remembering
some of their names this was the first one where
I felt like there was less archetypes like the
Megan Fox looking girl was kind of similar to
like she at first I thought when she was getting
out of the car of the guy dropping her off this
was going to be major Breakfast Club Vibes where
she was gonna be like Rebel Outcast or whatever
you know I thought we were kind of doing that with
the gymnast and all the stuff but then they were
all very similar you know they had some turns
but the the gymnast girl the Megan Fox looking
girl Molly girl they all had similarities to
them same thing with main dude eyebrow dude
um uh black guy and uh there's another
guy right pervert guy now he pervert
guy was different but they were all
like similar personality types you
kind of seemed until until eyebrow dude
Swift uh switched yeah yeah I think um
like the other ones kind of rely so much
on like such strong archetype right that
it makes them distinguishable but at
the same time I thought that this one
the friend group is the second best to me to um
to the third one to the first one to the first
one in terms of The Ensemble of friends like The
Ensemble of friends I really bought that they were
friends that they were actually like when they're
like because they're similar when they're buddying
at work and drinking I'm like okay I buy them all
as friends I definitely agree with you it's not a
it's not a knock on this movie that I thought
that there were some similarities between them
and it was less stereotypical because it was less
archetypes yeah but because when you're asking
how do I feel about the characters I think that
it is a little harder to distinguish them from
one another yeah I wasn't a like I think ever the
actors are pretty good and I like the cast overall
you weren't that in Denali Molly was the one I
had the hardest time believing the the problem
she seemed the most like cw-ish I liked her but I
think that they set her up they didn't necessarily
set her up for success and I think they did this
on purpose because when we first meet her she's
breaking up with our main character so when you
see that you're like F this girl even though we
don't know him and we don't know why and then we
find out she's actually doing it because she loves
him and she wants him to take this job yeah so
it's hard to then kind of like switch back because
we've already deemed her to be the villain in our
eyes just shows you don't know what's going on
Behind Closed do it you don't know about different
relationships but I didn't really think they have
Joe Jonas and Sophie Turner we don't know what
was happening I thought I liked them but I did
true I like them but I didn't feel like
they they had the best chemistry I hear
you yeah I don't think I don't think these
movies rely on them yeah they don't like
you know I think they had their priorities and
that was not one of them yeah and that's okay
yes I do think that this had the most serious
tone of them all like even though it started as
the comedy and you're like yeah and I love that
I think I think out of all the movies they the
the setup here I thought was the strongest because
it's really throwing you into their world in this
moment in time and not horror world and then when
it takes the horror World it becomes like super
serious which I really appreciated but because
this movie because this movie was 90 minutes but
it felt longer and in some ways that is a good in
a lot of ways that's a freaking fantastic thing
because it like pacing wise it it really took
its time and I really appreciated that and then
in some ways not most I would say vast majority
have been some little areas it would kind of feel
like it's dragging a bit and I I'm not exactly
sure which moments here or there were doing it
but I did have that feeling come up and I do think
that the like the humor especially wasn't clicking
with the tone they struck in this film like the
the humor did not fit it didn't bother me but I
it's not typically a critique I have and I know
that that's something bothers other people um
you know not everybody's always gonna be funny
and I think a lot of times movies try to make
themselves lighter so it didn't bother me here
I thought the kills were really strong in this
I was super freaked out I was upset with you for
not fasting forward several times uh something
about the I guess like office the spa and the
eyeball and the dentist to the previous one
now we know what my ick is so it just it freaks me
out people touching you and then you're gonna die
they did a great job with that the one kill
in this one that was just like okay it was the
wrench thing where it's just like all right we
gotta save some time just he's done we're gone
which is fine but it's a really good job in this
one and making the kills I want to say realistic
I don't really mean that as much as like I could
see my I felt it in my bones I was like oh my God
there's something coming to my eye oh my you
know well I think they brought it back to the
tangibility that the first one really had where
it's not like because like you could always sort
of feel death being like this clever guy creating
this like like the flick of a finger in a crazy
domino effect and the death stuff didn't really
do that this time around like it was still there
um but there was such dread and tension
leading to the execution of the victim that
I thought was so well done like there was such a
deliberate pacing that you could really feel the
the suspense I thought this movie had more
dread than the other ones specifically that
emotion and uh a doom and gloom a gloomy
Vibe over it like it felt like like it's
interesting to have like the weather be such a
specific thing because you could feel kind of
that cloudy weather sadness sort of looming over
this whole movie completely and I I appreciated
that underlying melancholic emotion that was
sort of permeating the entire film you're gonna
hate this but I'm gonna ask you to do it anyway
what is it look something up wrinkle rank them
um I I really love I I like this one a lot
I would still probably make it third okay
so what are you I would go three one five
two yeah it makes it sound like I don't like
too but I really do like like I really love this
franchise and I just there's one I don't like out
of all five and I would go three one five but see
there's things about this one that I prefer over
part three and part one that that's what makes it
kind of interesting for the that's why I love the
franchise because I'm like of other things in one
that I prefer over three there are things things
in five that I prefer over three and one there are
things in two that I prefer over the other like
every one of them has something that I prefer
over the others and uh and even though every one
of these movies that's the same concept characters
premonition yeah oh my God there's a pattern solve
the pattern boobs and and then uh death at the end
the there is something that they do different per
film that I that I really that I that that's why I
love this the franchise so much um it's wild that
we're so engaged and we binge these essentially
what's your ranking I think three two one four
five four oh this would be the fourth out of
them this would be the bottom of the five of the
of the four yeah I'm not stoked about that because
I loved this movie but I think that's what it was
so we're both with three at the top but you and I
had very different opinions on two yeah um and
so I almost want to do three two four one five
but before sorry three two five three two five
one four is what I almost wanna do okay however
it I I feel like I loved one it's just the
longest to go so that's like I feel like when
I first watched it I don't think it's fair to put
it in the fourth position I think I should still
put in the third position which is why this one
I think should take the fourth position I mean
think about it more then I'll be able to know if
five should be in four or five should be in three
I think the one a one two a seven
an eight and eight seven seven seven
uh I think I think for sure this one is
the best shot of them all I would give
it the the cinematography the lighting the effects
um just overall the look of it was I thought
the best looking one of them all yeah I feel
like this one had a bigger budget it also had
better technology because later a lot of times it
doesn't amount to it being like the best looking
Windows that's totally true I mean yeah Wizard
of Oz so yeah there's like a there's a visual
there's there's there is uh and I think maybe
because the film also took its time a lot more
that whoever their DP was on this was just uh just
did an excellent excellent job this uh five and
three guys I'd say the best shot ones at them all
it's interesting the both of you and I like three
the best yeah I don't know if that's a popular
opinion yeah I don't know either yeah you know
what I really hate that people do that I just did
I don't like when people say that their own point
is interesting it's interesting that and then
I say something like I think I'm so interesting
you know what so you know some of the interesting
corrects what I'm about to say is interesting
usually I think he's like that's a common thing
people say yeah but they go like you know what's
interesting this thing if I say it a lot what I
have to say who knows what's interesting maybe
you think it is let us know uh one more shout
out to Craig Perry thanks for watching shout out
to you guys all you Rejects at home special shout
out to super sexy rejects uh most importantly
special shout out to one particular super special
section not today no I really gotta go to the
bathroom before the last hour 20 minutes thanks
for watching appreciate it we'll see you for the
next Final Destination whenever that comes later
thank you